[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on P sensed in America Viv
ramaswami has electrified the race to be
America's next president age is 38 he
wants to be the youngest man ever to sit
in the Oval Office and his fans think
he's got the gumption and Pizzaz to do
it but how how can he beat Donald Trump
without criticizing Donald Trump and
with conflict raging in Israel does he
really have the experience to be leader
of the Free
World as I was waiting to interview you
I was looking at your tweets uh today
actually about Israel and it just seemed
to me and correct me if I'm wrong but it
seemed to me You' suddenly decided uh to
take a much more direct and tough
position and he said this now is the
moment for Israel to return to its
founding premise the Jewish state has an
absolute right to exist a Divine gift
gifted to a Divine Nation charged with a
Divine Purpose Israel has an absolute
unequivocal right and responsibility to
defend itself to the fullest applying
the only language its adversaries
understand the language of force and
what would David benguan say don't
depend on anyone else's fleeting
sympathies or permission to do it if
Israel wants to destroy herass Israel
should go ahead and Destroy herass if
Israel wants to destroy hisbah Israel
should go ahead and Destroy Hezbollah if
Israel and mosa want to pull off Munich
2.0 and take out every last leader of
Hamas whether they're hiding from do
hard at Dresden and host a red wedding
at the Four Seasons in Qatar they should
go ahead and do it now when I read that
I was I was a bit taken back because
your rhetoric about Israel I would say
before all this back in the summer was
not as strident as this well this in the
wake of an attack what I'm saying is the
principle the same the US should not be
involved
but when the US is not involved I think
that's better for the US it's also
better for Israel be able here's the
question going to ask you it it sounds
to me like your support for Israel is
they can do what the hell they like yes
but you want to be president of the
United States and there are many people
in America you know this who are
extremely concerned about the
proportionate scale of the Israeli
response already and it's only likely to
get a lot worse before anything is
resolved here is your support for them
unconditional because it sounds like it
is my support for their right to
National self-existence in self-defense
and carrying out whatever the heck they
think is appropriate in response to the
attack submitted on them yes it is not
our job to get involved in this in One
Direction or another historically it's
been America's position in the world to
be leader of the Free World to be almost
the world's Global
policeman and it sounds to me if you
were to become president what you're
saying is any country can in interest of
its own self-defense can do what the
hell it likes and you won't condemn it
is is there no limit to that well look I
think that within the bounds of
following international law right within
the bounds of the legal framework that
we all abide by yes it's not our job to
be the global policeman and I think
there's a lot to what you said there
Pierce that's true the historically
especially if you look at the last 25 30
40 years that has been the role of the
United States is to try to play this
role of global cop well I'm running for
president of the United States of
America and my job as the US president
is to look after American interests
that's a shift from The neoconservative
View it's a shift from the model of
liberal hegemony and I think part of
this is because I come from a different
generation that has seen the costs of6
and5 trillion dollars of our national
debt attributable to the wars in Iraq
and Afghanistan that did not Advance us
interests thousands of on thousands of
innocent lives sacrificed in those two
Wars alone yes I grew up into a
generation where we saw that I reject
that Vision but that means we have to
practice what we preach in all
directions that means this is Israel's
right to defend itself they should be
unconstrained and unrestrained the IDF
can I believe get its own job done for
those who would call for US military
involvement I say no my view to Iran is
you stay out and we stay out and that's
something that'll keep Iran out and we
stay out of it as well but that's a
different view also than saying that
then I'm somehow going to second guess
what decisions Israel makes no Israel
has a right to National self-de you
don't want to help them not militarily
diplomatically I do we have $3.8 billion
in Aid that's going to Israel I don't
propose cutting that off we've made that
10-year commitment for a reason but I
think actually I'm not sure that that's
exactly what BB would say me I gave you
what BB has addressed to Congress was in
1996 to also call out the unspoken truth
here appears one unspoken truth of those
carrier groups going to the conflict
area part of the reason they're there is
also to keep play Big Brother to Israel
to sort of say what Israel can and can't
do so I say go back to David Ben grian's
founding vision for Israel that's what I
would tell B you do what you need to do
okay but I would say to you the reason
actually those carriers have been sent
in is because it is absolutely in
America's national interest what happens
now in this war because if things were
to escalate and just before I sat down
with you I saw a statement from the the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia extremely
sensories demanding an immediate
ceasefire saying that they think this
this could be a disaster for the region
you've got president erdogan of Turkey
calling Israel overtly war criminals now
in at a rally in in Turkey this is
really escalating fast so I think we
need to deescalate it and I don't think
our military pres there help I'm I'm
going to come to how that may or may not
transpire but the idea that this is not
relevant or pertinent to America's
national interest is for the birds isn't
it well I'm not saying that it's not
relevant or pertinent what's happening
in the world my question is does our
military engagement help our national
interest the United Nations uh voted a
motion for
ceasefire in this war the United States
voted against that motion the United
Kingdom my country abstained where do
you sit on that I think the United
Nations has outlived its purpose I
personally think that we should have an
open conversation about the US's
continued involvement in the UN I don't
think that that should be a foregone
conclusion really so I want to be very
clear about where I stand on this as
someone running for US president I'm not
running for president of the UN I mean
Secretary General of the UN whatever it
is I'm not running for president of
Israel I'm running for president of the
United States of America and my prism
and I think that this is going to be the
foundation of a future that will lead to
Greater peace in the United States and I
think around the world is to be very
candid that my decisions will be made
through one filter what advances the
interests of the United States of
America and I don't believe that it
advances the United States of America
for us to assume the position of a
shadow icj in international court of
justice deciding what is or isn't
proportionate from our armchair position
in Washington DC when we have problems
of our own and threats of our own to
deal with and so my view is again Pierce
this is part of the broken foreign
policy establishment in both political
parties once you've crossed that Rubicon
then yes you're committed to take
stances on each of these question let me
ask this it's not my job to adjudicate
this as the US president pres there are
the injustices in this country to most
of the American people that's a massive
departure that would be a massive
departure and NATO so NATO I think is is
a different conversation from the UN I
do think that there's a conversation
first a table Stakes conversation with
NATO when you have a majority of its
members still not meeting it's minimum
2% but an American president has to have
a moral compass too about whatever's
going on anywhere in the world well I
have a moral comp question is this right
now there are thousands of children
you're a father two young kids I'm a
father of four kids
there are thousands of young children
getting killed in Gaza innocent
Palestinian kids half the half of gazer
kids women being blown to Pieces houses
and whole areas being completely
decimated a million garans have had to
move from the north to the South out of
their homes which they will not be able
to return to in most cases because
they've been destroyed and they're going
to be destroyed and I get that the
purpose that Israel's stated Mission
purpose is to get rid of Hamas and I
agree with them but how they do that the
whole world is watching and the other
parts of the region including Saudi
Arabia they on the verge of a new Accord
with Israel and now recoiling at what
they see as a disproportionate response
so as I disagree characterization my
question a long-winding question but my
question is on on a human level with the
moral compass required by an American
president do you not look at what's
happening now in Gaza and slightly
recoil at the scale of this and what it
may become in the next days weeks
potentially months do you not think do
you not think responsible American
president wouldn't say to prime minister
Netanyahu just hang on here so so if I
if I may Pearson I appreciate you
providing the backdrop for that question
and I'm not giving you the answer no I
know you're not I'm asking it yeah and I
I take it as a as a question yeah it's a
difficult question it's a difficult
answer I got my first obligation in the
way I've lived my my life to this date
is to my family to those two sons those
two boys we're raising and then we go
concentric circles to my nation I'm a
citizen of this nation not some nebulous
Global citizen fighting climate change
nebulously somewhere else I'm a citizen
of this nation if I'm running to lead
this nation as commander-in Chief I do
have a moral obligation this is my moral
compass speaking my moral compass is to
the United States of America and once we
have dealt with wage stagnation and a
border crisis and the people who are
suffering in this country the people who
are suffering for threat vulnerable to
cyber attacks super EMP attacks nuclear
missile attacks from a Russia China
Alliance that poses a great threat to
the United States and our citizens today
once we've dealt with that then maybe we
can get to hunger in the Congo after
that but that's the order we need to go
in yeah but this sounds if you don't
mind me saying this sounds incredibly
isolationist it's not isolationist but I
don't think the number one superpower in
the world can just ignore a moral
compass elsewhere in the world
particularly in countries which are your
allies I'm not saying don't get involved
or not I'm saying the question of
whether or not we get involved is is
decided through one prism of whether it
advances the American interest and so
there may be certain cases in which we
do make the determination that that does
advance the American interest I'll give
you one right now Taiwan if China were
to invade Taiwan right now I think it is
the job of the US to affirmatively
defend why because we depend on Taiwan
for semiconductors that power our modern
way of life so you would if you were
president you'd send troops in to defend
I would defend Taiwan and I'm not going
to Telegraph exactly which means there
are many why would you defend Taiwan
militarily but not Israel well I think
that right now we depend on those little
semiconductors for our modern way of
life just purely fin Israel also doesn't
need it but Israel provides a lot of
stuff to America well here's my point
each and this is the whole point Pier
say it's not some top down cookie cutter
analogizing I analyze each situation
independ a cool principle Israel is able
to defend itself right now and I think
Israel will be better able to defend
itself if we don't muddy the waters no
chance and it matters to the US your red
line you said to me was americ interest
it was if American citizens got attacked
we will hit you back 10 times harder
okay but American citizens were attacked
so that's what makes this conflict
difficult is Israel able to take care of
that job if American targets are hit as
American targets right let's say they
know they're hitting us on an American
base that's a direct hit on the United
States Americans get killed in Israel
well Americans kidnapped and taken
hostage by Hamas we need to well right
now you don't see any
prioritize getting those American
hostages out that is a top priority I it
is a top priority for me just to clarify
you would send American troops in to get
the hostages I would not take an option
off the table in a limited way to
protect Americans right you protect
Americans America First includes all
Americans you did say earlier that you
would not want to send any American
Military into their situation I don't
want US military involvement in somebody
else's War you just said you send troops
in to get the hostages American hostages
only the American hostages Special
Forces targeted but appears it is also
go and say are you American or isra
paying attention to the negotiations I
trust there are very clear delineations
that Hamas has drawn right now for
releasing civilian hostages of other
nations but just to clarify clarify for
this I mean you're not seriously
suggesting that you would send in
American troops down to get hostages
speci forces or otherwise NE but
literally only get American hostages
rather than say Israeli hostages the the
only condition under which we will have
shown up there was because they hold
American hostages right but but if we're
there we're going to do the best deal we
can to to to advance American interest
which includes releasing Israel host say
inconsistency to what you've now been
saying about it do you think at the
moment they are acting in accordance
with international law and the Geneva
Convention because many think I I
believe there's no evidence to suggest
that they're outside of that in the
context of the laws of just engagement
in the context of what Hamas did but as
the
UN boss clumsily put it this is not a
new conflict this is been going fair
that the Arab people the descendants of
Israel have 20 some odd countries yet
none of them will take on the
Palestinians even as they nominally
stand for them against
the so I think these are questions that
we should Elevate in our capacity as
Citizens and as leaders diplomatically
and I think this may hearing you
peers this may be actually we might have
a lot more common ground than the last
10 minutes might suggest there's a role
for
diplomacy
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
for today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
Ry sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pomp you mean you're
not going to support mayor Jose I am
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and the national soci party
for the preservation of the habitat of
the Lesser spotted M the problem lies in
the bureaucracy it's almost like those
highly paid Consultants don't really
know what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing labor would be
terrified of if Boris Johnson zoomed
back into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't
what he was most of them seem have given
off welcome to the talk it's really
great to be back my Little Darlings kids
think all they have to do is stay at
home be silly take pictures of
everything just shut down Tik Tok then
yeah problem problem
solve fit as a butcher's dog there you
go he's fit as a butcher's dog all right
but but he's now middle CL three us here
test the knock on effect is far larger
than just CO2 I nearly have empathy when
I'm speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me after
show kind to say I'm not I'm not a
Swifty critics I'd say me included got
former PMS all over the joint saying
things the last few days we have indeed
yeah great first show you having fun oh
a ton of fun King peer and King Cube I
think it's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying just cuz
they're skin folk don't mean they're kin
Folk when I say I am God you think I'm
joking or not you tell me I'm not joking
I'd rather do it on camera no no no no
if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
have you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy they about
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work it was a fabulous dinner until
you two uh mooned us thank God for talk
TV is not only the home of common sense
it's the only place where you get the
[Music]
truth was it diplomatic of you to say
that if it was left to you uh you know
you'd see Israel putting up the heads of
the top 100 not not that if it's left to
me if it's left to Israel and that's
what they decide to do I'm perfect okay
this is your idea yeah was that they put
the heads on Stakes of the hund top
Hamas leaders
that's not diplomacy is it and that's
going to be literally a pouring a bucket
of fuel onto a raging fire I I actually
think that that might be far better
Pierce as an alternative really to a
prolonged ground Invasion with Gaza
involving a bunch of civilians versus
taking the top hundred leaders of a
terrorist organization that are carrying
out a form of genocide isn't that the
kind of medieval barbarism which they
perpetrated on the people of Israel on
October the 7th which I think there's
one crucial difference the Civilized
World should seek to be above appear
there's there's a real difference there
a fundamental difference one is an armed
militia doing it against civilians
versus going after the perpetrators and
I specifically said the top hundred
leaders of Hamas and this is a fun
conversation it's interesting to me
because I've actually just taken
objections the other way saying that
that's far too Limited in scope right
just to say the top 100 leaders of Hamas
well why wouldn't we expand the scope of
who we hold responsible so yes I do
think that's diom bar Obama never showed
images of a dead AMA Bin Laden he didn't
feel that would be the right thing to do
he felt that would be too inflammatory
is my understanding two things in
response to that that's Barack Obama is
not my Arbiter of what counts as good
diplomacy or not and second is each
situation is different I mean each
situation is different about asking what
is in the American self-interest so I'm
not saying on the Israel point I was
very clear in my speech when I brought
this up that is I said it about three
times that is Israel's decision to
make not ours and I think that that of
provides a level of yes moral clarity
about who the leader of a Nation owes an
obligation to David benan had a vision
for Israel self-sufficiency makes its
own decisions for its own security
George Washington in his farewell
address in the United States of America
had a vision for this nation the lead
founding father of our nation that we
looked to the interests of our citizens
without foreign entanglements and I
think if we're honest about that I
actually think that that opens up
greater possibility for peace everywhere
because both our allies and our
adversaries can actually trust what we
say red lines will actually be red lines
because if they're crossed it means it
really violates the national
self-interest one of the other
candidates for president Ronda santz has
said that the students who've been
protesting across American campuses um
very Pro Palestinian a lot of Jewish
students feeling very threatened by it
some of these students actually beaming
pramas imagery to the buildings at
George Washington University and so on
that they should be taken out uh if they
have visas they should be revoked and so
on you've said you don't believe in that
because of Free Speech but again is
there no limit to that Free Speech if
people are actively supporting and
promoting a terror organization like
Hamas that's is hate speech not free
speech well to be clear I am a Ardent
defender of the First Amendment so I
agree with you so the First Amendment
does not protect against incite actual
incitement to violence to say hey go
kill that guy right there do it now
shoot him that's not protecting about
saying ham is so in the US the jurist
Prudence on this I mean the US is very
clear anything that is an expression of
an opinion is protected so if you're
expressing an opinion however heinous M
that opinion is protected by the First
Amendment all opinions are protected now
my view is some of those are heinous
opinions we're the country the United
States of America who said the Nazis
could March in skoki Illinois many
people around the world would disagree
with that but that's what makes America
itself I disagree vehemently with those
Nazis but I will defend to the death
this country in this country the right
of anybody to express their opinion
you'll defend to a death the right of
people to be Nazis in America I right
the right of people to express op being
a Nazi can involve more than that right
if you're taking action based on that no
heck no but if you want to but if you're
promoting and supporting a Nazi ideology
why would you want to accept that in
America I don't want to accept that the
way we defeat it why would you tolerate
it I don't tolerate it we don't tolerate
it through free more speech you defeat
it in the marketplace of ideas and we're
not tolerating it because think about
what you're doing to somebody who has
that nasty opinion and then tell them
that they have to keep it TOS you tell
people they can't speak they scream
would you allow people you tell people
they can't scream that's when they take
physical so I don't want to see that
would you be happy to see Pro Nazi no
I'm not happy of course I'm not happy if
you're president of the United States
you would allow it to happen Nazi
matches I I'll tell you something deeper
Piers this is how it works in the United
States it's not even my power to decide
whether to allow it to happen the
Constitution and the Supreme Court has
already L held that the expression of
heinous opinions is part of the American
constitutional life to say that the
government no government actor should
ever decide which opinions can and
cannot be expressed let me read you a
quote from Nikki Haley one of your other
uh Rivals to be president she says you
want to go and defund Israel you want to
give Taiwan to China you want to go and
give Ukraine to Russia under your watch
you will make America less safe now
we've discussed Israel you've clarified
your position on Taiwan and I think it's
significant that you now said you would
send in American troops to defend Taiwan
should China try and attack it I said we
would militarily defend you'd send
troops in milit it depends on whether
ground TR are actually what matter or
not you could talk about destroyers you
could talk about ssgn you would send
American Military in to defend the we
would militarily defend Taiwan yes at
least until we've achieved semiconductor
Independence I mean that wasn't and I'm
the only candidate who said it but this
brings me neatly to Ukraine yes which
was invaded and attacked it's a it's a
sovereign Democratic country it was
attacked Democratic with an asterisk no
no democr Asis well it had a massive
majority voted for democracy well much
of the regions that are occupied haven't
been represented in ukrainians in
Ukraine's Parliament for years right so
table Stakes discussion there but is
okay you can call it Asis democ I'll say
democracy but it was attacked and
invaded by Russia uh and you originally
when you first tweeted about it you were
quite censorious about what Russia had
done and pro Ukraine your rhetoric Pro
Ukraine but I but I but I found it
offensive I mean I've said this every
step Putin is a craven dictator okay
Putin is absolutely craving dictator
is's a war criminal I don't know I don't
have enough information as
the icj makes that judgment again the US
the US president you don't think what
he's done in Ukraine constitutes a war
crime based on what we've seen a lot of
it looks likely to meet the icj's test
but I don't think the US president it
makes it meets any test well I think
that a lot of people have committed war
crimes then on that basis right so you
can't just selectively single him out
well illegally invading a sovereign
country is a crime is it for us to get
on the same page is Putin an evil
dictator yes he is just because Putin is
bad does that mean Ukraine is good no it
does not okay this is a country that has
banned 11 opposition parties this is a
country that has Consolidated all of its
media into one state TV media arm this
is a country that celebrated a Nai in
its own ranks in front of the Canadian
Parliament zalinsky did this is a
country that's effectively threatening
the us not to hold its elections unless
the US Forks Over more money and also
against the backdrop Piers it's worth
wondering why that initial incursion to
keev went nowhere but luhans and donet
were easily captured without counter
resistance why these are Russian
speaking regions many residents there
don't even view themselves as part of
Ukraine they view themselves as part of
Russia and for the better part of the
last decade almost 10 years they haven't
even been represented in the Ukrainian
Parliament so we have to measure that
against you you would give Putin what
he's taken I won't give I won't give him
anything there's a deal what would you
give him I wouldn't give him anything I
would give him a deal what's the deal
he's going to take them well here's the
deal he has to exit his military
alliance with Xi Jinping end the Russia
China military Alliance that's the top
threat that the US to doal with Ukraine
in return what we get is a hard
commitment that NATO will not admit
Ukraine to Nato in truth that's just
keeping what about the land you well
this is the most important part is the
NATO hard this is what matters most to
Putin there's other parts of this deal I
can talk about on both sides the most
important element of each and then I can
go to the second most the most important
element is Russia exit its military
alliance with China we make a hard
commitment that NATO not admit Ukraine
to Nato which by the way peers that
violates we've systematically violated a
commitment we made back in 1990 James
Baker the US Secretary of State made a
commitment to tell this and and then
here we would freeze the current lines
of control what freeze the current lines
give Putin everything he I would freeze
the current lines of control what do you
mean what does that mean these are
Russians speaking regions that are
occupied today you would literally give
Putin what he's stolen you you would
give a guy I'm not giving anything I'm
giving him a deal what did you describe
him as to again it's conditioned what
did you call Putin he's an evil dictator
you give an evil dictator so are
countless others land he's stolen by
killing people you would give him the
land Pierce I'm not going to give him
anything I'm giving him a deal you just
said you give him the whole I'm not
going to give him that's your word not
mine I give him a deal what I would do
is no we would require Russia to exit
its military alliance with China what
threatens the United States of America
the Russian China military Alliance
you're president of the United States
and you say all right uh Vladimir I know
you invaded illegally a sovereign
Democratic country and they fought for
their not Democratic country Ukraine is
not a democratic country they F Ukraine
is not a democratic country I don't
agree with you I mean look at what
they're doing to the Ukrainian Orthodox
church right now it's just a myth but
we're having a mythological convers
is not Dem people of Ukraine voted for
democracy a massive majority except for
the ones that didn't vote that happen to
be in the regions occupied by Russia but
you would give this area they've stolen
back to the Russians right so you're
telling you're telling you're telling
every I would not do anything other than
we get what we want you're telling every
evil dictator in the world you can go
and invade any country you like take
whatever land you can in a Bloody War
for as long as you like here what I find
F and then eventually I'll just give it
to how much how many hours of your show
or minutes or seconds have you dedicated
to what a has done to Armenia Ando kabak
on the different region on the other
side of Caspian zero is probably the
answer just like every other me major
member of the media why because Ukraine
has been as successful in selling this
Pi Piper myth in the United States as
azaran has yet what aeran just did in
nagoro kabak over the same region dating
back to even September of this year pin
drop silence so if you're going to apply
that standard you would be applying it
far more broadly but applying your
standard as president of the United
States my my standard is stay out of
them all because if you're in Ukraine
for that reason the United States would
be in 10 other conflicts right now and
so you're selectively applying it if I
may say Pierce not even to the best
example you could make because Ukraine
is not a paragon of democra fashion but
I remember in World War II when the
Americans came in to help Britain finish
off when Pearl Harbor was hit
yes answer better late than never would
be my respons to that well
America when America was attacked to
itself then America did come into the
war and did help Britain win it that's
correct when America was hit that
happened and thank God they did and I
I'm grateful that America and Europe
should be grateful that we did and now
NATO can spend maybe 2% of its GDP on
military spending which it's still
failing to do so much for gratitude so
on that point I agree with you and I
agree with Donald Trump and he he did
the right thing when he said NATO was
obsolete he meant the way the finances
are not being paid by a lot of the
member countries they're just not a
majority of them
aren't
[Applause]
[Music]
this is talk
TV let's turn to conspiracy theories
people think you're a conspiracy
theorist H are you no I'm a conspiracy
realist I believe in actually some of
the most mundane so-called conspiracies
have been obvious realities hiding in
plain sight think I people said it was a
conspiracy theory by the way when I said
said that the like many others the co
pandemic originated in a lab in Wuhan
back when we were supposed to buy this
wet Market mostely did and most likely
that it did so I think has taught us
that many of things that we reject do
you believe the I'm Guided by fact do
you believe the Sandy Hook massacre was
a hoax no do you think the the parents
of those kids who died were actors no
okay so why did you appear on Alex
Jones's sh I learned from people that
were on the inside what was going on so
I had a long education over the last 29
years this has really been an education
and and so I just get deeper and deeper
into my understanding of how it all
interconnects what I'm hearing is the
story of a journalist yes guy who's
curious records things describes them
and and shares them with people why
would you invite someone like that onto
your podcast who give me some examples
of people you've have you ever called
isn't it called Truth have you ever
what's your podcast called truth truth
you the truth runs through free speech
and open debate you have the worst liar
in America a man who calls see I don't
believe in creating
let me let me finish my character
assessment of Alex Jones right I didn't
make a character assessment I'm about to
make one of him right because as you
know he was found guilty in October 2022
of defaming the families of the Sandy
Hood victims after years monetizing the
lie that it was a hoax and the families
of the Dead were actors he's been
ordered to pay a collective 1.5 billion
dollars to the people who he so
sickeningly defamed and there's you a
guy who wants to be president of United
States inviting this guy saying that
that was dead wrong he was dead wrong
now my view though Pierce is and the
whole premise of the podcast all the
people I've talked to Chris Christie
said when he heard you did that he said
I could care less for what Chris
Christie has to say get the was
disqualifying on his own well I think
it's disqualifying to anybody who
believes that we have to preordain who
we do and don't talk to you give
platforms to just blatant conspiracy
theorist to come on and talk about the
truth I think that part of the reason is
what's a conspiracy theory yesterday is
a truth tomorrow did you challenge him
about Sandy Hook did and I told you what
he said actually as far as I know it's
the first time I've heard it said I
think it was useful he said it was wrong
he regretted it he made a mistake human
beings have made mistakes the first time
he said he said it to me well good so
what you platformed him yeah well
interesting Pierce I platform why would
you do that cuz I spent the entire
interviewing interview going after him
about his Wicked lies and I also had a
mother one of the victims on cuz I was
on air at CNN open debate is good like I
like you for that reason but I think the
American way is not to decide there's
certain parayas and people we don't talk
to far left far right I mean look I went
on The Young Turks podcast and the
Republican presidential candidate
doesn't do either I practice what I
preach when a protester shows up to my I
I was in Iowa crazy protester just
barges in in the back of the event
Security's taking her out I said bring
her back we'll give her the microphone
that's just how I roll I believe it's
the founding Spirit of the United States
of America that all ideas get expressed
in the way we defeat bad ideas is
through free speech and open debate and
and so unlike others peers I
practiced you got again you got to have
some limits I don't I disagree with that
well then with with respect to the
expression of opinions violence is a
limit right I mean I don't stand for
violence of any form but Alex Jones's
lies did inspire people to commit acts
of violence against these families
people turned up and threatened them as
an act of violence he literally inspired
violence with his life the the
expression of a heinous opinion is
different than not and it was taken to
the court system we have I mean the
court systems have handled this that's
different from saying that some body
should not be talked to by a fellow
American I just don't think that's the
American way let me talk to you about
guns generally because there's another
horrible mass shooting yeah in America
in the last few days 18 people killed um
I saw your Tweet response and it was a
very conventional Republican response to
mass shootings of which there are now so
many you can almost hardly get over the
one before before there another one and
it was all about mental health and this
and this and the one thing you didn't
it's really important top it's not like
a mental health I mean this is a real
fundamental but many other countries
have mental health problems just at the
same level that America does the
difference about America almost
exclusively of anywhere in the world is
that America has 400 million plus
firearms in circulation so when people
are mentally unstable or sick they have
easy access to guns and you didn't
mention the word gun in your in your
statement and I was curious why not do
you not think guns play a part in gun
massacres well obviously guns
definitionally per your you know
questions tological there guns play a
role in guns massacres they don't play a
role in massacres of other kinds do you
think guns kill people I think people
kill people using guns and using other
instruments to do it I'm CU look as as a
British citizen who has a home in
America I can go and get a
semi-automatic rifle very easily
tomorrow yeah and I'm not even an
American citizen I just have to apply
for a hunting license give my American
address and I and I'll get access to any
Firearms I want I can I can kick myself
up like Rambo right Legally Legally what
I can't do in America is buy a Kinder
surprise chocolate egg they baned on
safety grounds well I think that makes
no sense you're a very bright man I'm a
medical Absol can you explain to me why
it's deemed more dangerous that I should
have a chocolate egg with a little toy
inside that might choke people compared
to an AR-15 semi-automatic rifle that
could slaughter a lot of people in a
very short period of time so I am a pro-
freedom person and so I'm not going to
sit here and defend some other foolish
restriction that the United States has
on a million things that I'm generally
against but I can speak to the Second
Amendment the Second Amendment is not
about a technocratic judgment about
maximizing or minimizing the number of
people who were killed the second
amendment is about something else
altogether it's analogous to the
discussion we just had about Free Speech
it's a different value judgment are
there risks to allowing Free Speech yes
there are but we bear those risks
because that's who we are that we trade
that risk off to say that's how we
preserve Freedom when it comes to the
First Amendment the second amendment
makes a similar value
judgment the purpose of the Second
Amendment actually wasn't to allow
people to have the freedom to hunt
that's not what it's about it was about
repelling and keeping a foreign in that
case started British Monarchy at Bay
it's like mutually assured destruction
in the Cold War both sides have nuclear
weapons well that's how you assure a
stable peace it's a mutually asured
destruction relationship between the
citizens and their government between
the governed and their government right
that's what this is about and so why is
the United States of America still for
all of our imperfections 250 years into
this ball game still the place that when
you open the borders as sadly one
Administration has people don't go
running out but they come running in why
is it the country that still gives hope
to the Free World one of the reasons why
is the Bill of Rights and the Second
Amendment is the one amendment that
gives teeth to all of the other
amendments in that Bill of Rights so
that's a value judgement we make the
second amendment was not written with
the question of what minimizes the
number of deaths those are other
policies it was you could arm yourself
as part of a well regulated militia and
then over time actually until the 80s uh
in America it was considered by the
Supreme Court to mean just that and then
as the NRA got more political and became
less apolitical and some hardcore
Republicans got onto the board of the
NRA they then put pressure on the
Supreme Court which they eventually were
successful in doing in reframing the
interpretation of a second amendment to
mean an individual right to bear arms
and what Hasen I think the history is a
lot more complicated but what has
happened and it may be a complete
coincidence but what has happened since
that reframing of that interpretation is
that the number of mass shootings in
America has begun to Skyrocket so I
think that in the data that you cited a
lot of confounding variables one of
which is the rise of Mental Health
crisis in this country you could look at
data points over certain periods where
before you really saw a rise in violence
you could see per capita gun ownership
being about flat over the same period
that you did see violence and killings
rise one of the biggest explanations is
the shuttering of psychiatric hospitals
in this country you had to draw the
lines of correlation there are many ways
to draw lines through a scatter plot
over the same period that you saw the
shuttering of psychiatric institutions
you saw almost a direct inverse
correlation in the other direction in
the rise of violent crime in this
country
[Music]
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong your face just starred out
at me me and you conquer time who wins
you do you know what I love about t
today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
richy sunak I'm so rich frankly uh I'm
going to take the side of Booz du Brits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the reservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us the one thing labor would be
terrified if Boris Johnson Zoom back
into full Focus Boris Johnson isn't what
he was most of them seem to have given
up welcome to the talk it's really great
to be back my Little Darlings kids think
all they have to do is stay at home be
silly take pictures of everything just
shut down Tik Tok then
yeah problem
solved fit as a butcher's dog there you
go he's fit as a butcher's dog all right
but but he's now
us here test the knock on effect is far
larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
know you're probably going to boot me
after show
this kind of say I'm not I'm not a
Swifty critics i' say me included got
former PMS all over the joint saying
things the last few days we have indeed
yeah great first show you having fun oh
a ton of fun King PE and King C I think
it's only room for one king man you know
what I'm saying just cuz they're skin
folk don't mean they're kin folk when I
say I am God you think I'm joking or not
you tell me I'm not joking I'd rather do
it on camera no no no no if it's on
camera we're not doing an interview why
we'll explain why how do you feel about
that influence that you have you better
be careful we're coming for your
children there buddy Med Nation yes I'm
going to do you're going to Res yes cuz
I cannot continue my work it was a
fabulous dinner until you two uh mooned
us thank God for talk TV is not only the
home of common sense it's the only place
where you get the truth
[Music]
tell me who wrote this after January the
6 it was a dark day for democracy the
loser of the last election refused to
concede the race claim the election was
stolen raised hundreds of millions of
dollars from loyal supporters and is
considering running for executive office
again I'm referring a calls to Donald
Trump I wrote those words in my book in
the same ju position to Stacy Abrams
Phil you stand by them so look I think
that here's what you went on to say
Trump delivered another tale of
grievance no one likes a s loser one of
the worst victimhood complexes of all
said his claims about the election were
weak so here's my point what he did was
downright abhorrent do you I mean do you
stand by all that stuff you said about
Trump and January 6th the reason I have
a different View today is that they have
been going after him so there's a time
and place to say something okay I tend
to not say what everybody else is saying
at the time
and part of the reason is what needs to
be said needs to be said when it's hard
not when it's easy but I think you were
right to said at the time I said the
same thing I fell out with him over at
the time so so I would have I would have
done things very differently I would
have done things dramatically
differently and I will note to you I'm
running for president in the same
election As Trump to be clear but
against the backr of not being
prosecuted for this I think it's I take
the other side of this to you don't
think he had the election stolen do you
well I think that to tell you the truth
what the election stolen it was stolen
in a different sense of the word and we
can go into this if you want big Tech
Google and other search algorithms and
the interesting point I think that
that's that's really where the real
issue is as I said to him when I
interviewed him I said you're fighting
the wrong stol election claim and he
said what do you mean I said Well when
the New York Post story exposing Hunter
Biden's laptop that was the real issue
CH when that was basically vaporized by
big Tech to protect the bidens and R you
both looked at the same polls those
would have changed the result of the
election it could have Chang so there's
evidence of a potential St election so
on that I kind of agree that's that's
what I've said
all that's not the position he takes
well yeah it's fine and we are allowed
to have different positions my position
also is the 2016 election was the real
election that was decisively stolen from
Trump the one that he won for sure
decisively everyone agrees he W because
he wasn't allowed to govern with an
impeachment in how are you going to be
every time he gets indicted it's quite
extraordinary situation but every time
these politici if I just finish my
thought let me finish indictments are
wrong okay but all of them I think all
of them so far are wrong his mother
Theresa I don't say Mother Teresa but
he's not a criminal so nearly a hundred
criminal charges they're all baseless so
the ones I've read I mean those are four
indictments we're talking about I read
each one thoroughly okay okay each one
is each one is using a novel legal
Theory so so even innocent assumes that
the thing that's even being alleged you
genuinely believe he's innocent of
everything he's been charged with I
think we can talk through each one and I
yes I believe the answer is innocent
because the legal fiction of the charges
themselves are made up interpretations
of the law that have never been used in
this country how are you going to beat
him
by convincing voters that I have fresh
legs I am from a different generation
and we're in the middle of a war in this
country and I do believe that we're in
the middle of a war between those of us
who love this country and are founding
ideals but Trump loves the country and
we're all on the same side of this war
right we're all Trump myself Etc I even
think many Independents and Democrats
are on the side of this war those of us
who love this country and are founding
ideals and a fringe minority and I do
believe it's a fringe minority who hate
this country and are founding ideals
that's the real de think the whole so
how am I going to beat him how am I
going to beat the rest of the Republican
field the question is who is the right
General to now lead us to victory in
that war well here's one of the tricks
half the people on the other side of
that war Pierce are people younger than
me who never learned those ideals in the
first place we can bring them along too
now we're talking about somebody who has
not been wounded in that War I have
fresh legs I am 38 years old 5 years
older than Thomas Jefferson was when he
wrote the Declaration of Independence
but less than half the age of the other
people who were running many of them so
I believe I have an ability to take our
America First agenda to the next level
and honest to God I would love Trump as
an adviser as a mentor telling me
exactly where the bodies are buried in
the administrative state or otherwise to
be able to go further he rolled that log
over we saw what crawled out you thought
about him as your potential VP I've
thought him as a mentor I don't think he
would take the VP job although I haven't
asked him I'll keep it on the list but I
think that you temped to R it's highly
unlikely that you tempted to run out and
commit a loot of crimes to get
indictments to get your poll numbers up
going to do
that I'm going to wrap up very soon but
just do a few little quick ones and the
truth is Pierce I just think it's really
important that again
you understand this I think you
understand this I'm not mean to be
preachy but there is a difference
between making a bad judgment and
committing a crime and I think it is a
danger to our Liberty I'm not saying AAL
conflate those I'm not saying it's a
criminal and read those indictments it
is an extraordinary State of Affairs
where someone can face that volume of
criminal indictments whole numbers keep
going up I mean in England that
candidate would be dead and buried after
the first barrage of them right however
unfair they may be that's on the
politics of it I think that the reality
is the opposite here is the fact that
all of these indictments are coming at
the same time right as he's running for
office using novel legal theories that
have never been PR I think a lot of that
has has Merit has to do with the fact
that he's running I think they're
overing the Sul as I would say the
opposition I think they're they're just
determined one way or another youever
hang out with Trump you ever talked to
him I've talked to him a few times when
was the last time it's been a while yeah
probably before the first debate easily
yeah do you think he should debate is he
being bit gutless not getting on that
stage I think as long as he's this far
ahead I kind of get it but I hope that
we have a chance to have open discourse
in this race but you know it's like
you're the NBA Playoffs the team that's
you know number one by a stretch gets a
buy you know we're about to have the
third debate I know I'm focused on
making sure that I'm the clear second
before think you've been very listen I
think you're a great energizing force in
the race I've said this to you from the
very start you in much shorter context
many times but we've sparred we've had
our fun but I like it and also I think
you you get out there and you put
yourself in the Lion's Den which I
respect I do respect it and I had to say
we haven't really got into it but all
the woke Madness stuff you've been
absolutely Rock Solid on and I
completely agree with you I appreciate
you saying that and the thing is and
this also about me is related to one of
the other questions you were asking I
wrote the book woke in back when it
would actually you did was a risk to
write that book yes you did now the
reason I I don't I mean I share all the
same beliefs but I don't talk about as
much
because I mean any Tom Dick and Harry
can go criticize wokeness today right
it's the new popular thing it's almost
what the cool kids are doing the people
who are doing it today were the people
who are too afraid to do it in 2020 I
think what I I absolutely respect about
you saw the dangers of it and you saw
that it was becoming under the guise of
liberalism it was becoming a new form of
fascism and I I think you served a
valuable public service and blowing that
lid up and I I feel it's beginning to
turn I I think it is too the majority of
people are just sick and tired of it
well I think I think this election makes
a big difference in that result just in
terms of not even the laws we passed
there's some element of that but just
the tone of national character that we
set in the country because if you think
about what allows you know wokeness or
anything like it to to
Fester it's a deeper generational hunger
for purpose and meaning and I think it's
been a long time since we've had a
president that has revived and spoken to
our national character character and
that's half the job I mean if people
Grill on policies that's just half the
job the other half of the job is do you
have an understanding of what our
national character is and then can you
actually bring it back well let me ask
you about your character young people
were able to do that let me ask you
about your character very quickly how
how rich are you varies by depending on
the stock market you know uh billion on
a good day and uh you know maybe 600
million on a bad day US Dollars yeah a
billion on a good day yeah maybe a
little more on a good day yeah do you
like being a billionaire I don't
particularly relish the title I am not
one of these people that that's been a
life achievement of mine I I'm thrilled
that this country allowed me to achieve
everything that I have I'm proud of my
accomplishments I don't apologize for
success but I also don't fetishize green
pieces of paper I think sometimes it's
something that leads people to deep
unhappiness and I've been around a lot
of them and I'm careful to make sure I
don't become one of them either we we
try to live in a way that you know maybe
would reflect a fraction of that net
worth in a way that actually hopefully
allows our family to avoid some of the
traps that some of my wealthier friends
have fallen into your wife aova I think
is how she pronounced it she said your
two best qualities were your joy and
optimism is that what she said that's
nice of her what do you think of that is
that is that true yeah I think I'm I'm a
naturally a very optimistic person it's
funny she says that because she's the
person who experiences my crankiness the
most at times but but there's a joy and
optimism in there on certain days it's
buried more deeply than others when was
the moment knew she was the one for
you we were hiking a mountain in it was
a Flatt top mountain in Colorado we were
in uh Rocky Mountain National Park and
she was the one who was beating me all
the way up the hiking trail she had
actually done kilamanjaro not long
before that but we were we were going
pretty hardcore to the top I had been
there to the top before and I wanted to
show it to her and it was just the final
maybe 300t 200 feet to the to the top
but there was a massive snow storm that
set in and she's somebody who's made it
to the tops of these mountains before I
said I was going to go and wanted to
wanted to you know make sure we saw that
through and she grabbed my hand and said
we're going to come back and do this
sometime in the future but we're going
to have a long future together and we
turned around and we made it all the way
back down that mountain and and you knew
and here we are yeah how did you propose
I proposed it was actually uh you know
the the real story I mean the cake was
baked long before I proposed I think
that we wanted to get to a place where
both of our families were all there we
knew we knew what the destination was
going to be and uh yeah i't told the
story before but she she sort of said
all right all right like at this point I
don't really care about the ring or
anything else if you don't get on this
you might find me proposing to you un
let's just get this over with so I got a
uh so I was you know put the perfect
ring plans to one side and we got a
little Ring Pop and we did it in the
streets of New York City a ring pop
what's that it's like a little lollipop
as a ring it's like a big Ruby you gave
your wife a lollipop ring she was
thrilled with it and and billionaire man
what were you thinking yeah I wasn't at
the time you know was working my way up
but uh but we got her her did you at
least got her red ruby ring to follow
though did you go on bended knee I did
oh yeah yeah we we went through the
whole you went on bended knee oh yeah
yeah we did with your lollipop ring with
with the lollipop ring yeah it was in a
nice case though it was a very nice case
and what is finally what what is the
secret to to married life
o I think we um practice actually is is
a good way to look at it I think that if
you look at every iteration
as a round of practice then that
presumes that you're on the same page
about the destination you're just
iterating and practicing to to you know
get
to the per the version of perfection and
so it's never perfect but it's about the
pursuit of perfection and romance are
you a romantic guy I I I maybe on a good
day yeah what's the most romantic thing
you've ever done I don't know what I
can't I can't profess on my own self-
romantic
thing
I don't know I feel like a little bit uh
I'm not I'm not a guy who's going to Pat
I could think of some examples right now
but I'm not it's not the kind of thing
that I want to give me a little bone you
know I think romantic bone I think that
it was um maybe one of our I I don't
know how pora felt about it but our our
Valentine's Day gift she's she's a tough
one to please because she's not really
into uh you know stuff she's not a she
has stuff she's not particularly into
stuff but I thought about what I could
do that that was better than her which
are few and far between but I gave her a
tennis lesson and we actually and we
actually and we actually went through it
and she's naturally athletic person but
we picked something up that we were then
able to do together for a while really
yeah so I know it's a small thing I
don't know no but's no big ceremony
around no I get that yeah it's a nice
thing yeah and she and she loves it she
seemed to like it yeah who wins I mean I
it's the sport I've played since growing
up she's a better volleyball player
that's what she played so you basically
got her to play something something you
knew you could beat her at I had to pick
something had to find something she
usually has me beat out is that
basically your character at a nutshell
you know it's interesting I'd have to do
some some Freudian introspection for
that one this might that might have been
the toughest gotcha of the whole
interview the whole thing was leading to
that it's good to see you it's good to
see you man I appreciate it yeah I
enjoyed it thanks very much thank you
[Music]
man
[Applause]
[Music]